la voile marc pajot devrait logiquement
gagné cette nuit la route du rhum il est
à moins de 100 milles de l'arrivée il a
fait une petite escale de moins d'une
heure à la martinique tout à l'heure
pour consolider la poutre centrale de
son catamaran qui avait donné les
inquiétudes pajot maintenant à plus de
sept heures d'avancé sur le deuxième
bruno peyron le troisième c'est le
canadien mike birch est le quatrième
c'est eric loizeau l'arrivée sera jugée
à la guadeloupe
gilles cozanet est déjà sur place ce
n'est pas toujours facile d'être un
paradis touristique français installé à
5000 km de la métropole
parce que le tourisme ne peut pas être
la seule ressource du nil comme la
guadeloupe
d'autant qu'elle subit elle aussi les
effets la crise économique la durée
moyenne des séjours est passé de 6 jours
4 en 1980 à 5 jours 8 en 1981
les activités économiques de la
guadeloupe sont fragiles essentiellement
agricole elles sont ici soumise aux
conditions climatiques la production de
rhum a diminué de 8% en un an et par
exemple la récolte de bananes a été à
moitié détruites en 79 et 80 à cause des
cyclones économies fragiles mais aussi
dépendante la guadeloupe à un déficit de
sa balance commerciale de deux milliards
et demi de francs
d'où la nécessité pour elle de trouver
de nouveaux débouchés en particulier
dans sa zone géographique naturelle peut
pas lutter pour les grenadines mais
pourrait être une base de plaisance en
direction des îles vierges américaines
dans le nord ont fait en europe on
connait pas les îles vierges
on connaît les grenadines alors que du
point de vue beauté c'est aussi beau
outre qu'elle peut re stimuler le
tourisme la route du rhum a surtout
permis de lancer la plaisance en
guadeloupe un domaine qui lui échappait
totalement jusqu'ici au profit de sa
grande rivale la martinique
c'est aujourd'hui un des rares domaines
en pleine expansion en quatre ans son
parc de voiliers a doublé et le nombre
de marina est passé de 1 à 3 pour
activer économie et tourisme les
opérations de relations publiques ne
sont pas inutiles la route du rhum en
fait partie l'édition 2009 178 avait eu
un retentissement considérable dont se
félicite encore observateurs et
responsables économiques
indéniablement ça a un impact et c'est
pour cela que nous avons été
disons partisans une seconde édition et
pour ne rien vous cacher nous sommes aux
partisans d'une troisième édition
encore un goy de l'ovaire la route du
rhum donc dont l'arrivée sera sans doute
jugé cette nuit c'est marc pajot arrive
à bon port et que le vent continue à le
pousser vers la première place